great uh thank you all for having me um
and i um i appreciate being here and i'm
sorry i'm not in prison um
i had tried to make that work but i
couldn't figure it out
i also appreciate
giving the camera angle it feels like
i'm giving a talk while crouched in the
upper back corner of a lecture hall
which is probably usually where i'd want
to be when giving a talk so i'm going to
take some comfort in that
so this uh this talk is a very applied
talk but hopefully it'll be of interest
and it comes out of trying to think
through
how people go about analyzing multi-site
or blocked randomized trials they show
up a lot in education you can think of
them as you have a bunch of schools and
you're randomizing
students within schools to treatment and
control and then you're looking so
within each school you can estimate a
treatment impact and the question is how
do you combine all of those individual
school
impact estimates across all of the
schools to get an overall estimate of
impact
and so there's a little story that mike
put together about
sort of setting the stage which i like
so i'll go through which is mike's
collaborator alex um comes to mike and
says i'm planning an evaluation that'll
randomize 6000 people within 20 sites um
alex works in like early
college like community colleges is
something to think about there can you
write uh the part of the analysis plan
that describes the estimation model for
the overall average itt intention to
treat effect
and mike who's my collaborator
probably thinks something like why don't
you do your own job but he goes okay he
likes to help and then what he did is he
reached out to me so we can think
through this simple question and try to
come up with whether there is any sort
of definitive answer
short story is there's not one of the
many answers that one might give would
be an estimator that would be something
like a fixed effect
estimator where you have within this you
would fit a fixed effect model you have
a fixed effect for each site you have an
overall coefficient beta for your
treatment effect t is your treatment
you have some residual you would use
some sort of robust standard errors and
you'd call it day so that is one
standard recipe but the question is what
is that recipe doing and is it the best
recipe
and so this talk is going to look at a
variety of recipes and we're going to
compare those recipes across a variety
of data sets to see if these decisions
matter in practice
so first
let's talk about the s demand what are
we actually estimating when we talk
about an overall average treatment
effect in a multi-site trial
now what i'm about to show you is very
basic but i think it just sort of sets
some ground um
sets the groundwork or
whatever word goes there my words are
failing me um
and uh it also will just make everything
follow so we'll have a common language
so
first we talk about the program effect
for a person this is not something we
can ever estimate but we can certainly
uh hypothesize about it you've probably
done the show all week
so
you have a person and you have the
potential outcomes you have the program
or no program you treat the people in
the program uh if you're in the program
otherwise not you have these y1 and y0
and then the difference the beta i would
be the individual treatment effect for
individual i
now the fundamental
problem of causal inference is we can't
actually see both those potential
outcomes so we have to look across
groups but from a conceptual point of
view we can still think about all those
individual effects
so for a group of people at a site
here's a site we have a bunch of people
and we can think of those pairs of
potential outcomes and we can average
them across the site so we average the
individual effect for person i and site
j average across all those people you
get uh beta.j which would be the average
impact for that site
all right so in this case the average
effect might be 0.25 because we're
inducing one person to be happy with our
treatment
so
where this gets interesting is in a
multi-site trial here's a multi-site
trial with two sites if the sites are
different sizes we immediately have two
potentially different s demands so in
site one
beta dot one is .25 in site two beta dot
two is point five
the overall person average effect is
point four one six but the overall site
effect is the simple average of the
quarter and the half which gives us
0.375 so we actually have two answers
and when you look at what people say in
literature when they're busy analyzing
multi-site trials which they spend a lot
of time doing i would say that it is
extremely unclear as in no one really
ever says anything about it one way or
another whether they're estimating a
person average effect or a sight average
effect and as we're going to see it
turns out that people are often
estimating neither of these effects at
all
so we can write
for
as an s demand we can say beta person is
just the person weighted average of the
site average effects and then beta site
is the simple average of the site
average effects
the next issue is are we estimating for
the people we have in our experiment or
the super population this is very common
to talk about in the causal inference
literature and is not so common to talk
about outside of the causal inference
literature
so this point is worth making
so here's our individual evaluation
sample those are the people that we
actually rounded up for an experiment
here is some very large population and
in fact we probably have some relevant
superpopulation that is not all the
people that we can imagine but some
target subset
this quickly gets into issues of
generalizability of which there is a
long literature but in this particular
instance the reason we think it's
relevant to make this distinction is
when you look at various ways of
estimating and calculating standard
errors it's often very unclear and
sometimes hard to figure out whether you
are estimating an average impact for the
finite sample or for the super
population when you use the sort of the
standard tools that people use for
estimating impacts for a multi-site
trial
so this gives us four s demands you can
be estimating a person average or a site
average s demand
and you can be looking at a finite or
super population framework
i'll also add that other work that i
have with some other collaborators
actually points out that the number of
super population frameworks that we have
is more than one
deciding what is being sampled from what
and for example are the do we have an
infinite sample of
do we have infinite population of
students within each of the sites so
it's an infinite infinite model or are
we sampling sites where the students
themselves are finite but we have an
infinite population of sites uh we can
also think of like large finite
population which opens the door for
finite population correction there are
many variations of this
which are much more salient when you're
thinking about this as a blocking kind
of style rather than a multi-side
experiment but at the end of the day a
multi-site experiment is just a blocked
experiment so um
so a lot of the literature goes back and
forth even though the language doesn't
necessarily flow
all right so four s demands there's
actually more but those are the four
biggies
estimators um what we did is we looked
around and we tried to think of all of
the various ways people might estimate a
site average
or estimate an overall average impact in
a multi-site trial we came up with 15 or
so
and i'm just going to go through them
relatively quickly
most of them or all of them really boil
down to
a weighted average of the site average
estimate so beta hat our estimate of the
overall average treatment impact cup
boils down to wj which is some
weight given to site j which is a
function of how many people are in that
site and other features and then beta
hat j which is the average treatment
estimate for that site so you can think
of beta hat j as the
average of the treated people in the
site minus the average of the control
people in the site
and we take all of those individual
estimates we get a weighted average to
get our overall single estimate
cross-site estimate
all right
so
here are uh how we estimate those beta
hat j just to be very explicit we
randomize in the site in this case we're
randomizing um
sorry we're randomizing one person to
control and three people to treatment
which is blue and then our beta hat j is
just going to be the average of those
three people minus the average of the
one person left over and we get 0.6 for
our estimate
and
great i just want to make sure that
everyone's on the same page
all right so classes of estimators of
all the estimators we identified we sort
of have three families or general styles
of estimator one is design based this
comes out of
basically the name and style
causal inference world there's all sorts
of linear regression the econometrics
models uh classic linear regression some
weird versions of that and then there's
multi-level modeling which is
particularly prevalent in education
contexts where you have a random effects
model um
and you fit your data to that
so for design based estimators in the
world of education there's a fairly nice
sort of overview of them written by
peter choche peter chose and others
wrote this software package called rct
yes which basically analyzes all sorts
of randomized experiments using
very low assumption design based methods
and gives you point estimates and
standard errors
and they wrote this as documentation for
that package
all right some nice features they're
simple they clearly connect to the s
demand you look at a design based
estimator built into that is a very
clear statement of what it is you are
estimating which is not the case with
other estimators they're generally
unbiased not always but usually and
there's software so they're easy
to use
the design based person
average is just what you'd expect it is
the person weighted average of the
individual site
at estimates and the design based site
estimator is the simple average of the
individual site estimates so here we see
that those weights are just very
directly part of the estimator you just
follow the recipe of what are you trying
to estimate and you end up with your
estimator
the standard errors that go with this
there are
straightforward standard errors they
boil down into two
kinds of standard error the finite
sample standard errors
are name and style they
uh look at the variation of the units
within each of the groups and then you
average those variances across your
groups with with the weights that we're
looking at in these formula
the super population standard error
estimators what they actually do is they
look at the variation in the beta hat j
and the variation the beta hat j is
going to be a compounding of the
estimation uncertainty of
each of the beta hat j themselves and
the uncertainty of some sites have
different average treatment effects than
other sites and by looking at the all of
that together by looking at the
variation of the beta hat j you can end
up with how much extra variation there
is by generalizing to the hypothetical
super population
so it's a sampling framework rather than
a assignment mechanism framework
for linear regression there's a lot of
textbooks so i'm not going to give you a
citation but we identified eight
different variants which are primarily
how you calculate the standard errors
and whether you include interaction
terms or not so fixed effects models is
where you have that fixed effects and
then you can calculate standard errors
using heteroskedastic or cluster robust
standard errors or you can just use the
old style standard error
it turns out that these are precision
weighted they're neither person nor site
average estimates in terms of their s
demand
but given that the weights are
proportional to nj the number of people
in a site times the proportion of people
treated in the site times the proportion
of people not treated in the site
if you have
the same proportion of people treated in
all your sites they collapse back into a
person weighted estimate so we basically
said or believe that the implied s
demand of a fixed effects estimator is a
person average
estimate person average average
treatment effect
but it's looking for precision so it's
going to focus more on the sites that
have more balance in the treatment
assignment because you have more
precision in estimating impacts for
those sites
weighted regression is you just add
weights to try to de-bias your estimate
to to make your weights um
no longer precision weighted and they
coincide with the design-based
estimators we just discussed
and then finally you can fit a fully
interactive model where you interact a
site dummy with your treatment
assignment and then as a second step you
average those individual estimates to
get an overall
person or a site average using those
weights that we saw for the design based
these fully interactive models they're
useful because you can do covariate
adjustment very naturally whereas the
design based estimators it's unclear how
to do covariate adjustment and in fact
if you read the design-based literature
what you'll see is the design-based
covariate adjusted estimators tend to be
interactive linear models where you
calculate the standard errors slightly
differently
and then finally we have multi-level
models there are three that we identify
that are sort of widely used
one is called the fixed intercept random
treatment coefficient this is like the
in vogue current cool model
and what it does is have a fixed effect
for each site and then you put a random
effect for the treatment
impact for that site so this is allowing
different sites to have different
treatment impacts and the fixed effects
is gives you a de-biasing effect if you
use the second model the random
intercept random treatment if you have a
different proportion of units treated at
different sites you can actually bias
your treatment effect estimate because
of those different proportions and the
correlation of the random effects can
cause some trouble
finally there's the random intercept
constant coefficient where you just have
a single treatment effect this collapses
to the fixed effects model it's slightly
different but it is negligible how
different these two are which means that
even though it looks like you have a
random intercept which feels like a
super population kind of quantity in
fact the that one is estimating a
finite person person weighted s demand
the other thing about multi-level models
is it seems like they're estimating a
super population site
kind of quantity because you have this
random effect for the average treatment
effect of the site and then the beta
there where you have beta dot j equals
beta plus a random effect in the top
center
of the screen
i don't know if my mouse is doing
anything
but this beta
um you would think that it's site
averaged but in fact the ferc model is
adaptive if it doesn't see that there's
a cross-site variation then it collapses
to precision weighting and you can see
that in the weights
expression there where that tau hat is
the amount of cross-site impact
variation and if you don't estimate any
then that's going to be zero and you're
going to end up with your precision
weights again
so it's adaptive it tends towards site
average when you have evidence that the
sites are different from each other
okay
so
we have four s demands we have a bunch
of estimators we've classified those
estimators as to what s demand they're
targeting and then the question is like
are we just wasting time does any of
this matter
and so what we did is we looked at 12
studies
these are all actual large scale
randomized evaluations with multiple
sites and we just fit all the estimators
to all the studies we also ran a
simulation
inspired by these studies has the same
sort of statistical uh properties in
terms of how much the inter-class
correlation coefficient and how much
variation there is and how much
treatment effect um all of that good
stuff
the simulation sort of allowed us to dig
into a few extra questions but the
fundamental piece of work is what
happens in practice do these decisions
change your answer in any way that we
care about
so the first research question is does
the choice of estimator or estimate
matter for the estimate
and here's like one particular
trial where here are all of our
estimators and you can see that some of
them gave a slightly higher estimate
than the other and we have a difference
of about 0.202
standard deviations or 0.02 effect size
units which is not the biggest deal in
the world because we're usually looking
for impacts at around 0.5 0.1 or 0.2
and also we see that in this particular
study it was pretty bleak overall like
there's not evidence that there was much
of an impact
if we look across all of those studies
and all of the outcomes of those studies
that we had we can categorize how what
is the difference between the smallest
estimate we get across the 15 and the
largest estimate in some sense this is a
researcher degrees of freedom plot like
how much wiggle room is there just by
choosing a different way of analyzing
your data and this is a measure of how
much these decisions matter in practice
most of the time they don't really
matter and this is across
whether you're targeting a site average
or a person average effect
occasionally however we are seeing
differences in the impact estimates of
0.075 or even 0.1 which is
i would argue a big deal
if we group by whether they are person
or site targeting we see that for all of
the person weighted estimators on the
left it's really hard to change your
estimate
they get
you can sort of move them a little bit
towards .01
in terms of a shift which is not really
that big of a deal
for the site average however we can
start that's where we see all of the
larger shifts we can move things
a much larger amount on the site side
does the choice of estimator matter for
the estimate of the standard error
here again we're looking at a tennessee
star and we see
different widths of our error bars some
of the intervals seem wider than others
the question is how much
so similar to the prior
plot on
beta what this is is the ratio of the
largest standard error to the smallest
standard error across all the estimators
regularly we're seeing that some
standard errors are more than 200
percent
larger than other standard errors
sometimes we get four times the size so
depending on your model you pick you are
going to get standard errors that are
very very different
if we divide all of our estimators by
type of estimator finite versus
superpopulation person versus site we
see in the top left
that across all of the finite person
estimators all the standard errors are
basically the same for the super
population site we can get a great deal
of variation
in the standard errors
we checked whether standard errors were
calibrated this is from the simulation
study generally the standard errors are
calibrated and what's really driving the
difference in standard errors is whether
you think you're doing finite sample
inference or super population imprints
that the cost of generalizing to a super
population is large and the standard
errors for a superpopulation inference
are therefore going to be much larger
but that's not the entire story
the other piece of this is that standard
errors are sometimes hard to estimate
for finite sample
standard errors
the standard errors you can estimate
them very well
there's not a lot of instability but for
the super population standard errors the
standard errors in in the blue box plots
there we're looking at what percent of
the um
what is the ratio of the standard
deviation of the standard error i.e the
standard error of the standard error to
the actual standard error this is
again from the simulation studies across
a wide variety of scenarios and we're
essentially seeing that there's um for a
super population standard errors there's
a lot of instability in estimating those
standard errors it's hard to get a
handle on the um the precision
um in particular sometimes the super
population standard errors are so
unstable that this is our empirical data
in the top left
pink rectangle we're seeing that the
standard errors sometimes in the super
population are smaller than the standard
error for the finite which is
nonsensical
this is due to instability in estimating
the superpopulation standard error
that's sort of what's driving these
discrepancies
and this again just digs into from
simulation
the chance of a superpopulation standard
error being lower than an estimated
finite is is actually quite high
especially when
the cross-site impact variation is
relatively low
so what's happening is when you have no
actual variation in your impacts across
sites the super population can
erroneously estimate that there is just
due to bad luck
that's going to inflate your standard
errors
sorry
um when there's not very i got that
backwards when there's not very much
cross-site variation
then what happens is the super
population you can end up
with stan your point estimates look
under dispersed and you end up with a
standard error that is not taking into
account the within cluster sampling
variability because you've essentially
erased it by your cross
site
sampling variability just due to bad
luck
so i mentioned that some of these
estimators are precision
weighted they're attempting to they're
giving you a biased estimate in exchange
for increased precision question is how
does that play out in practice
so first
if we looked at fixed effects models
versus unbiased finite sample person
models we see that
across all of our empirical estimates
you get essentially the same answer the
difference between these two estimators
is very very small and we saw that
earlier
we also see that the standard errors are
essentially identical as well
which means that these precision gains
from using a fixed effects model is
neither giving you much bias and it's
also not giving you much increase in
your precision
for ferc which is also um doing a
trade-off where the more cross-site
variation there is the more it tries to
estimate the site average the less
variation there is the more it tries to
estimate a person average when you
compare that to the unbiased design
based
we see that the point estimates move a
lot more
and we also see that the standard errors
are
all over the place sometimes
ferc is
doing better than the design based and
sometimes it's doing worse
so
it's really hard to sort of make a clear
call on what's going on when you use
ferc which is a biased but hopefully
more precise estimator than the design
based
and that's because
um and we to explore that we did a
series of simulations to look at that
and came to the conclusion that this is
due to instability in the design-based
estimator if you actually look at the
design-based estimator's performance
in terms of estimating standard errors
it's really really shaky it's a hard
thing to estimate cross-site impact
variation
and so if you're relying on that to get
your standard error estimate you can end
up in all sorts of weird places
which is what that shows all right
just very briefly um at the end what
about covariate adjustment
we re replicated everything um with
covariate adjustment and we see
a small change um in estimates so if
these are looking at how much the
estimates change
with and without covariates across all
of our various outcomes the gray line is
a shift of 0.01 and we see that most of
the time
point estimates the point estimate shift
due to covariate adjustment is less than
that
we also looked at whether our standard
errors were improved so that red line is
the standard errors are the same and
then if we go to the left that means
that covariate adjustment has reduced
the standard errors by whatever percent
and we see most of the time that the
standard error reduction
is less than 10
so covariance basically in the context
we looked at aren't really included
improving precision much at all
so just a quick pitch for our paper
our paper
which is published somewhere it's
published in the
journal of research on educational
effectiveness um it has two additional
papers tacked to it one is a technical
appendix which basically walks through
all the estimators i discussed gives
some details and notes on their use it's
a nice reference that i would encourage
people to check out if interested
and then you can also look at the
multi-factor simulation which looks at a
lot of these questions under
hypothetical multi-level model
degenerating process
and sort of digs into some of the things
that i alluded to
overall the stand that we take is the s
demand choice matters a lot
and the beta estimator choice matters
for the site supers demand but doesn't
really matter otherwise and the standard
error estimator matters for sight but
less for person
and then the super population side
estimators differ the most that's the
hardest thing to estimate is the super
population side average effect
a lot of instability there perhaps that
means you should turn to more bayesian
approaches when doing that kind of work
all right that's it um i hope that was
of interest i'm happy to talk offline
just email me
whatever you like happy to share the
paper although that's out in the world
and
oh there's also an r package that just
sort of implements all of these
estimators for a given data set so it's
really easy to compare these estimators
to each other and i'm happy to share
that as well
thank you
okay